hi there reject turn your bird off
I'm sorry I thought you know he gets to
work here he doesn't downloads a good
look at shoutouts and we do this thing
let me write 15 emails I get to you in a
second I pick up my phone he said we
already started what is it my guests are
my clock always just go ahead start the
video Tara it it likes to laugh I kind
of laugh she is welcoming to this family
guy try not to laugh challenge today you
like family guy right oh I do very
simple rules here Tara you don't laugh
you don't laugh you don't smile you
don't even smile no that's cheating you
can kind of find a way to transfer that
energy from the laughs and to that you
know you move it you move it around the
face so I could just at this doesn't
count I mean if you have to to make
yourself not laugh I totally get it
great he gets it are you speaking like
the Family Guy guy I think I I think Joe
Swanson didn't realize I was doing crazy
back to school that's been eating our
Tomatoes try to get like a tone this
time I want to make bruschetta keep the
kids just want you know I'd like to
watch two full movies before I go to
work fine I'll take them but you better
keep those goggles cuz I'm gonna put it
that get used to that house is your
house Peter I'd sit here and chat with
you but I need to get back upstairs to
Loretta because it's our anniversary
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
excuse me I'm gonna go masturbate I
haven't been doing a good job I'm gonna
try better
well have some father-son time so I'm
gonna measure your penis we're gonna see
who this is awesome bunch of cops in
uniform hanging up my restaurant this is
gonna be cool in that time Ben Stiller
taught me how to be myself
Oh leave me now Ben Stiller what I need
you more than ever I've taught you
everything you need to know Peter no
it's time for me to go help another
child I guess I just fooled myself into
thinking you'll always be with me
I will Peter I will always be with you
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
I knew there was only one active Lane
and Quagmire leader gave me a beer that
tasted funny and when I woke up I was
wearing lipstick and a wolf suit well
you know what nothing works out for you
right because you've got a negative
attitude but you're come on your let's
go play I don't feel like it I have a
nail in - okay Louis 15 seconds on the
clock name something you sitted popular
fruit something in your closet
shields Gary monsters your favorite
holiday 9/11 something you do all the
weekends oh come on boy we always used
to go close on its cheese trust me
they'll have everything I need
oh no credits at the end or nothing they
just really they know how to end it yeah
you go what it's done you'll know that
first half was really there's something
about that jackass bit I'm sorry was not
even focused on trying not to laugh that
he's this is called hood the cart the
roof roof the cart roof good it's also
had a lot of old-school Family Guy bits
as well like sometimes I see bits here
that I'll you don't remember I have a
flash of a memory of it but I don't
really remember the jokes that whole
thing with the wolf I don't remember
that I have a copy or watch every family
guy either so I definitely don't
remember yeah that was it that punchline
their cockadoodledoo I had the fashion
present passion project when that
happened I wouldn't when he shot them
all all the way I was like oh that's
like what it's like to get bullied and
you end up being like
mad and you like I don't know you're
angry all the time
who's your family and then you you lose
your mind and then you're like
eventually in your 50s you're like
listen I'm gonna try to be a writer make
a film my favorite family guy kind of
bits are the ones that they really just
dragged out like sometimes I do that
with just like it is bantering for a
long time that concept of a wolf who
gets picked on that takes it out of his
family he gets addicted to drugs like
there's nothing to do with the plotline
of the Family Guy episode it's random as
big III think that's so funny these guys
obviously just get so high and just I
just imagine imagine writers were people
just hi just throwing ideas at each
other that's what I imagine that's funny
about my hair the days I'm like you know
what I'm gonna let my curls fall Wow
curls fall I'm gonna slip that out I'm
just gonna let that out yeah never
cooperates me with me when I want to be
on camera but damn does it look good
when the curls are out you mean yes look
back yeah when the curls are out I like
when I'm just out and about yeah rolling
it out but then see what we did there oh
oh why don't you just tie it up do a
little man bun status I can let me see
what it looks like show the show that's
hard to do with I mean I don't have a
hair tie it needs to be a top man bun
though not back it needs to be up here
oh yeah so we can also oh I've never
done that I don't why not I do that oh
my god get a hair tie and do man bun
I'll do it for you look at this this is
what Gregory drinks on his on his timed
when he's guys see me he gets a good old
bang Lemondrop going I just need me
myself and I to be here he needs a whole
can of this just to stick with me they
all fell asleep yeah you're like keep up
with okay
yeah man bun you're doing it see what I
mean we're getting there at the top man
button going this is what you need in
your life truly let's face it okay so
you gotta get it up top okay and then
just bun it bun it a little bit and
that's the man bun time holy [ __ ] Oh
hipster as heck every girl is like loose
oh my god rice is so hot who is the guy
in the man bun there this is so if you
want you want to put more energy into it
you can really just pin up the rest of
the hair in the back sort all of it
would you button it up that's pretty
crazy yeah but you can do a half up half
down like it did here for you
I haven't you look you do I have a job
leave in the comments if you like it
laughs John looked like he that
obviously I've never seen John that
happy before right now he already
commented on the video saying loving it
like what's I think I have some tombow
loving it what is that front McDonald's
this is what it means to be attractive
yeah oh my gosh you're realizing your
true like you're you're realizing your
true worth now oh yeah all because I put
his hair in a man bun do you see the
things that I do for him when I'm here
do you guys realize that do you guys see
why I drink these I do here well guys
million dollar ideas right here yeah go
ahead Tom new channels officially over
nope
unsubscribe channels done tell me an
Instagram model now I cannot wait to
pursue my real dreams of likes and
comments and body shaming he's gonna
call it number one man bun I look like
Machine Gun Kelly
Eminem's favorite rapper at number one
man bun don't click notification bells I
think from now on when your name if
you're not a video I got to get some
thing that just floats your floating
head saying
ring men metal we had so many more
people watching this video for us on
YouTube go follow her - yeah all right
I'm just gonna go stare at a mirror now